what's going on with you what's new
how much
I hate the idea of you down there by
yourself all the time just drink it not
fine I appreciate it
but it's I'm fine ever since I heard the
how we and I suppose you're wondering
why I called you over here I didn't need
to go where
our basketball coach had a heart attack
the other night they need a new coach
Jack and you know you give seem too many
good no the last time they made the
playoffs back when you were playing
Marcus right that's right how many
threes did markets make last year the
percentage of 26 yeah wonder why they're
leaving you open it's cuz they don't
think you could hit the ocean from the
beach he just backs that show as breath
[Music]
so I like coaching so far great getting
used to the players or players
you I could live
I heard you're coaching basketball yeah
he's pretty busy keeps my mind off other
things to him what you said
I spent a lot of time i market myself
carry other name I have a lot of regrets
[Music]
Dan's online I want you taking a shot
why is that so hard for you really well
maybe the best player on team
[Music]
they're suffering I just want you to be
happy again
but you gotta want it too
keep pressing traffic taking charges
carry
you guys on this tonight
[Music]
you
you